is the iPhone 15 Pro really that much
better than the 14 pro well over the
past few weeks it seems like my life has
been consumed by using and testing these
new phones and we have found a lot of
real world differences that others
didn't talk about both good and bad so
let's get right in and answer if you
should get an iPhone 15 Pro I want to
start out with USB type-c because I
didn't think that it was as big of a
deal in the real world like most people
made it out to be especially since I
mostly use max a for charging but but
there were a few times when I forgot to
charge overnight and I started looking
for a lightning cable and once I
remembered it was so nice to just use a
USB type-c cable which I have everywhere
for my other devices just plug it in and
charge up with that Apple didn't lock
down the USB type-c port like many
people thought so you could just connect
it to a display and it works great and
connect it to a ton of USB type-c
accessories even hubs and everything
just works so that is a nice upgrade now
as far as the charging speed it has not
gotten any faster still takes about an
hour 45 minutes for a full charge and if
you're using ma saafe up to 4 hours
which is insanely slow now based on the
battery health issues that we reported
on with the 14 pros and the overheating
issues on the titanium 15s which we'll
talk about in just a bit it does make
sense why Apple didn't want to make it
any faster now onto battery life Apple
quoted the same 23 hours of video
playback and 75 hours of audio playback
but who in the real world shuts
everything off including cellular and
just does that now in the real world if
you guys use really power hungry
applications the battery life is still
about the same but if you do more simple
tasks the 15 Pro actually gets up to 2
hours of better battery life which is
really nice now this is of course
because of the new 3 nmet design but
with the efficiency cores that are a lot
more powerful that is what makes the
difference now for me personally I was
thinking about possibly switching
fulltime to the smaller 15 Pro but after
these tests I will not be able to do so
now as far as the design and the Comfort
I do like the new titanium design but
with the dark colored models they really
show off fingerprints and smudges a lot
more than I expected and the Coatings
can actually scratch off quite easily
revealing the natural titanium which
might be why the new Ultra 2 still only
comes in natural titanium now titanium
also brings the weight down by about 19
G but to be honest with you guys the
weight difference in the hand is not
that noticeable with the smaller 15 Pros
like it is with the larger and heavier
Pro Maxes the 15 Pro is more comfortable
with the rounded edges and I love how it
feels in my hand but most people use a
case especially now that we've seen how
much easier it is for the screens and
the back glass to break due to the glass
being curved into the edges instead of
being protected by the edges like on the
14 Pros so to protect your new iPhone
check out our partner mf's new MOS vegan
leather lineup which has an amazing
texture while being very durable making
their new Mac safe case a perfect choice
especially since Apple stopped making
leather cases their lineup is fully
modular so you can add on their slim
battery pack which uniquely has its USBC
port on the side and then pair it with
their Snap-on wallet allowing you to use
your phone in any orientation while
charging which is also perfect for
standby mode you can also use both on
the go or if you don't need the extra
power or that day you can leave it at
home and just take the three card wallet
stand which I have been using and
recommending for years they also have
this amazing invisible tripod stand
which instantly unfolds and can be used
in many configurations like browsing
macrophotography video call theater mode
and more while folding down just as
quickly the prices are great too for all
of these modular accessories so check
out our partner mf's Moes products using
the links below now almost every iPhone
launch Apple's been improving speaker
quality and loudness without mentioning
it at the event and we saw a really big
improvement with the 15 Pro Max and the
15 plus both having the same amazing
speakers this year unfortunately though
the 15 Pro was not blessed this year and
the speakers are identical from the 14
pro so go ahead and take a listen to the
difference
[Music]
[Applause]
take back to where we
started
get me out
[Music]
[Applause]
of now this isn't a huge deal but it
still sucks when the larger ones had
such a big upgrade and the same thing
with the displays they are identical
this year no difference in brightness or
quality whatsoever now on the inside we
do have an upgrade with the new A7 Pro
chip now it has a few new features we
have rate tracing for upcoming games in
the future and metal effects upscaling
but overall in Peak Performance the
difference is one of the smallest that
we've had in years but the efficiency
cores on the other hand can handle more
tasks now so you don't need to put the
performance cores to use as often now
thankfully we do have another real world
difference that Apple didn't talk about
and that is with the new x70 5G modem
from Qualcomm we get better real world
speeds and reception both indoors as
well as Outdoors so if you struggle in
some areas or slower speeds well the 15
Pro will give you better results now the
biggest Buzz around the 15 Pros is
overheating and yes I have felt that the
15 Pro runs hotter when you're using it
and especially when it is charging now
Apple blame third party software which
definitely has a part in it and they
just released an iOS update to help with
this but that is not the only issue the
new a17 Pro now can use up to 14 watts
of power which is is about 40% more than
the a16 and the 14 pro so that puts out
a lot more heat and with that titanium
is way worse at transferring heat than
stainless steel there's a lot of
articles about this and how titanium can
cause excessive heat buildup and
companies actually use titanium when
they want to insulate heat or stop it
from spreading and some regular people
have even placed a single washer to stop
heat transfer so even though titanium is
nice and it is very strong it is
definitely not an upgrade in every way
and with that said after we tested the
software update from Apple it has
definitely made a difference in how hot
the phone gets when you're using it now
I'm not sure if it more tasks are being
done now with the efficiency cores or
there's something else going on but it
is definitely helping and screen dimming
has also been reduced which is nice now
a lot of people upgrade their phones
because they want better photos so
getting into cameras unfortunately all
of the sensors in these phones are ident
identical we have the same 12 megap
selfie camera the same Ultra wide the
same 48 megap and the same 3x telephoto
camera from the 14 pro Max and that 3x
camera well it's been around now for the
third year so I was not really expecting
the differences that we got looking at
these photos and starting with the old
3x camera here it is so hard to see any
differences switching to this low light
shot they look so similar and then
cropping in um I see a little bit less
noise on the 15 but at the same time
maybe a little bit less detail and both
of them have artifacting issues we still
have that same 15x maximum zoom and
looking at these shots right here I was
surprised that the 14 Pros 3x camera
actually looked slightly better than the
15 pros and then looking at this
portrait shot they look very similar we
have slight differences in color and I I
would say I not seeing any detail
difference and I actually slightly
prefer the warmer look under our studio
lighting of the 14 pro so honestly I was
really disappointed because the 15 Pro
Max has a brand new zoom camera and as
you'll see all the other cameras
actually got some updates so I don't
know if Apple just gave up on trying to
make it better with software or they
already maximize the quality they can
get from this threeyear old lens and
Camera combination now getting into the
other cameras in this portrait shot we
have a little bit of difference in
saturation and colors and maybe slightly
better blur you could definitely see the
same thing in this shot we definitely
have more saturation and looking closer
we have a dramatic difference in detail
um the 15 main camera looks a lot better
even though the hardware is the same and
that is because Apple included 24
megapixel photos now instead of 12 so
the quality goes up and it's doing quite
nice looking at this shot right here
also fairly similar but we have some
improvements and looking closer we
definitely have better detail and a more
natural look in this portrait shot it's
harder to see the difference but then
getting a little closer you definitely
see much higher quality and detail with
less artifacting as well looking at the
selfie shot one interesting thing is
that the 15 front camera is actually
wider than the 14s and then getting
close we see a lot more extra detail in
the shot even though they're both 12
megapixel with the same Hardware so I
don't know if it's just software
differences um better processing for
warping where it doesn't have to crop in
as much but it looks nice and in this
shot we see a massive difference we have
so much flaring on the 14 pro which we
had issues with the 13 and 12 Pros as
well and that is greatly reduced pretty
much gone and then if you look at the
sunset the HDR is so so much better in
the shot the same thing here where the
sky looks much more natural and you see
the colors popping through with a bit
more contrast and in this shot right
here you can really tell with that
Sunset especially if I crop in where the
sunset looks way more like what your
eyes see and at the same time we also
have improvements in detail and noise
and the scky thing is that the hardware
is the same this is just due to Smart
HDR and the 24 megapixel and the regular
iPhone 15 and 15 plus they use the same
a16 bionic that is in the iPhone 14 pro
meaning the image signal processor is
the same and they could be getting this
result if Apple would allow it in
software but they're not allowing smart
HDR 5 or 24 megapixel mode for the older
phones just because they don't want to
and that sucks and looking into night
mode here we have a selfie shot you guys
could see how much more crisp the 15s is
and then looking closer we have a lot
less noise as well and then looking at
detail and the faces much more detail it
just looks really good and it seems like
this new processing is able to just
freeze action a little bit better and
quicker um and maybe stack more photos
and that is really sweet to see and
here's an ultra wide shot and the 15
Ultra wide looks so much better in every
way and once again the actual Hardware
is the same here is a 1x photo you guys
see how much more detail we have there
in all of the brush and in the sky and
the stars and then in this nighttime
portrait it is clear even without
zooming in how much better the 15s looks
and punching in we have way less noise
more detail the colors look better it's
a dramatic Improvement and then in this
nighttime handheld star shot wow we're
getting way more stars with smart HDR 5
and the improved processing and that
looks incredible now I don't know what
an iPhone 15 or 15 Plus's photo would
look like in this scenario um and how
much of this is a17 but it's clear that
a lot of these differences could have
came to the 14 pro with software updates
but they're not now Apple also added
prores log recording and external USBC
uh ssds or cards to be able to record to
that so that is really nice and with all
of that said if you really care about
getting the best photos possible the 15
Pro might be worth it for you at least
with the other lenses not the 3x but
then again the 15 Pro Max is definitely
better with its new 5x lens that is so
much nicer than the 3x if you guys want
to see a full comparison with that
included we did an awesome one that is
so fun to watch so go ahead and check
that one out and to be honest with you
guys even though there are some
improvements with the 15 Pro I think
that this is one of the worst updates
that Apple has made here over a year and
comparing it to the rest of the iPhone
15 lineup it definitely is the worst one
in my opinion all the other phones had a
much bigger upgrade and difference so
unless you really need some of these
features I would say if you can score a
great steal on a 14 pro if you want to
choose between both of these I would go
for that or if you're just waiting to
upgrade and you can wait another year to
for the 16 Pro to come out I think that
is when we're going to see some major
differences in the regular size Pro
iPhone so you guys let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below go ahead and check out moft as
well in the description click that
Circle above and check out one of those
great camera comparisons right over
there this Max and I'll see you in the
next one
[Music]
y